hey everyone it's sarah with
registerednessrn.com and in this video
i'm going to talk about benzodiazepines
and as always whenever you get done
watching this youtube video you can
access the free quiz that will test you
on this material so let's get started
benzodiazepines also known as benzos or
bzds
are a group or class of drugs that
actually calm the central nervous system
therefore they're known as cns
depressants now these drugs can have an
anxiolytic
sedative or hypnotic effect on the body
and whenever we talk about the mechanism
of action
how these drugs actually work on the
body like with the receptors
and the specific neurotransmitter it
affects you're going to see
how these drugs actually cause these
effects to occur
in our body now whenever you're studying
these drugs you're going to see that
there's various types of benzos
available for use
some are very potent some are short
acting some are long
acting and it really depends on what's
going on with the patient
to determine what type of benzo should
be used
now how do you recognize a
benzodiazepine say you're looking at a
patient's list
how do you know if this is a benzo or
not well there's two things you can look
for
and you're looking at that generic drug
name the first thing is look at the
middle of that name and look for a
z e or a z o in benzodiazepine we have a
z
present in the name that usually tips
you off that this is a benzo
another thing that you can look at is
that most
end in lamb or pam except for
two and this includes chlorazepate
and chlorodiazepoxide now some popular
ones that you will
see in practice that do follow those two
rules
are alprazolam lorazepam
clonazepam tenazepam diazepam
and midazolam so now let's talk about
what benzos are used for
what conditions are they really good at
treating well we've established
that benzos are cns depressants
so they're really good at treating
conditions where
there is too much cns stimulation
where these neurons are just rapidly
firing we have
too much activity going on up there so
we need to calm things down
and they're great at treating patients
who experience anxiety
seizures panic attacks or whenever
they're withdrawing from alcohol
or they're having trouble sleeping like
insomnia they can also be used before
a procedure and many times i have given
a patient before
a tea a trans-esophageal echo or a
cardioversion
versed that is midazolam and this helps
calm that patient down it also helps
them not really remember
the procedure and so they're really
helpful for that
and these medications can be given
various ways you can give them
iv you can give them po i am
intramuscular
rectally etc now let's talk about the
mechanism of action and how benzos work
to actually depress
the central nervous system and to
provide that calming tranquilizing
effect on the body
in order to achieve this it all deals
with a neurotransmitter
specifically known as gaba and gaba
stands for
gamma-aminobutyric acid so whenever a
benzo is on board in a patient's body
what it's going to do
is it's going to amplify the effects
that
gaba already normally has on that
central nervous system so it's going to
exaggerate the effects
that we need in order to treat whatever
conditions going on with our patient
now gaba is considered an inhibitory
neurotransmitter
now what does that mean well first let's
talk about neurotransmitter a
neurotransmitter
is a chemical agent that is produced and
released
by a neuron hence why we call it a
neurotransmitter
and it transmits messages to
a specific structure that it was
actually designed
to communicate to this could be a gland
or many times it's a neuron so it's
going to send these specific messages
and these neurotransmitters i like to
think of them as like
little raindrops that are raining down
and they're going to go
to where they need to go on let's say
that neuron because that neuron that
it's communicating with is going to have
these special receptors
they're just going to set there and
accept that specific neurotransmitter so
this neurotransmitter can either have an
excitatory effect on that specific
structure it was designed to target like
that neuron
or an inhibitory effect now sometimes
neurotransmitters can have both effects
but it really depends on where they're
acting in the body but
gaba is one of the main inhibitory
neurotransmitters
so let's talk about the difference
between an excitatory inhibitory real
quickly
so an excitatory tran neurotransmitter
what it's going to do is it's going to
excite and it's going to
increase the potential of an action
occurring like
the neuron firing and sending that
message so it's going to make sure that
message is sent
an inhibitory neurotransmitter just as
it name its name says
it's going to inhibit so it's going to
decrease the potential of an action
occurring so it's not going to really
allow it
and it's going to inhibit that message
from being
sent so that's where gaba gets its
qualities because it's going to inhibit
decrease that firing
of that neuron so that patient can chill
have that calming tranquilizing effect
on the body
now to help us really understand
and see how these neurotransmitters
actually
are released from the neuron onto a
receptor site
let's look at this animation so here you
can see that this neuron is releasing a
neurotransmitter
the neurotransmitter is in yellow and
it's raining down
and for that neurotransmitter to be
successful
to send whatever message it needs to
send to the other neuron
whether it's an exciting or inhibiting
message it must
bind onto its special receptor
which will help complete that action now
when the neurotransmitter
gaba is released from its neuron it's
going to go and bind with
gaba receptors and many gaba receptors
are found
in our limbic system and this is a
system that helps us
process our emotions and really dictates
the way
that we behave so there are two types of
gaba receptors there's gaba
a receptors and gaba b receptors
benzos are going to specifically affect
gaba a
receptors so that is what you want to
remember gaba a that's
what we care about for this lecture so
gaba a are
really interesting because they are
considered ligand-gated or
ionotropic receptors and these terms
just really describe
how they work and how they operate
whenever they are being affected
by let's say benzodiazepines so whenever
binding occurs so we have benzo
binding to the receptor along with the
neurotransmitter gaba
neurotransmitter which you're going to
see here in a second it's going to cause
a
channel to open whenever that channel
opens ions are going to move
in to the cell and whenever this occurs
it's going to cause hyperpolarization
and this is going to cause that
inhibitory action
where it's going to inhibit potential
action from occurring hence we're going
to get calming tranquilizing effects
and we're specifically talking about the
ion chloride so now let's take a
closer look at these gaba a receptors
and look at their unique design and how
they work to actually
cause this effect so hopefully it'll
seal this concept in your mind
okay so the gaba a receptor has
these divisions and it's divided into
five
subunits you have two alpha subunits
two beta subunits and one gamma subunit
and on these subunits we have a total of
three binding sites there are two sites
that are for the neurotransmitter
gaba and gaba will go here and bind with
this receptor in between both of the
alpha and beta subunits
then we have a binding site specifically
for the benzodiazepine chemical
and it's going to bind here in between
alpha and gamma so it has its own little
special
site and in between all of these
subunits
right there in the middle is like this
little opening this pore
and this is what will open and allow our
ion to move
down into the cell and cause hyper
polarization
so we have gaba neurotransmitter raining
down
from our neuron here and it goes and it
sits at this binding site and it locks
down on it
so there's our gaba then the patient has
taken a benzo so that chemical is there
in the body
it's going to be here and it's going to
bind to its site
and whenever this occurs what's going to
happen is that this
channel down here is going to open up
and once it opens up these chloride ions
which are negatively charged are going
to go
down into the cell what this does is it
causes hyperpolarization
it's going to make it negative and this
is going to decrease
firing potential so decrease that action
potential
and it's going to hence cause a calming
tranquilizing effect so we're going to
have an amplified effect of how
gaba would normally work on that central
nervous system
so this is great for a patient who is
having
anxiety panic attacks or having those
withdrawal symptoms
from alcohol will help depress that
central nervous system
now let's wrap up this lecture and let's
talk about the nursing responsibilities
side effects and patient education
pieces that you want to provide to the
patient
who is taking these type of medications
and to help us remember
all those important concepts we're going
to remember the word
benzo so b is for beers list
what is this well this is a list that
the american geriatrics society
created of drugs that older adults
shouldn't really be taking
because it can cause harmful side
effects to them
and benzodiazepines is on that list and
whenever an older adult is taking a
benzo it
increases the risk majorly of toxicity
dependence on the drug abuse of the drug
and injuries such as falls so as a nurse
if you do have an older patient that is
taking one of these medications
you want to keep this in the back of
your mind you want to educate the
patient
or the patient maybe they have a
caregiver about this
and watch out for injuries especially
getting up
moving they need to call for assistance
because they can fall and really hurt
themselves
and if you would like to see all the
medications that is
actually on this beers list i have
posted a link
in the youtube description and you can
access that list so it can help you
in practice as well then we have e for
alcohol
opioids and cns depressants other cns
suppressants that should be avoided
while taking a benzo so you definitely
want to educate the patient if they are
going to be taking a benzo
that these other substances do not mix
with benzos
because they actually increase the risk
of overdose and death
and the fda has actually issued a black
box warning
on benzos and has educated and told
people do not take this drug with these
other substances
because that can happen and then we have
in
for not recommended for long-term use
benzos are really best for short-term
use because whenever they're used
long-term there's an increased risk
of the patient becoming dependent on
them abusing them
and having withdrawal signs and symptoms
so if they are taking these long term
they just can't quit
cold turkey and stop them abruptly they
have to be tapered off them over
a period of time next is zzz
for sleepy hypnotic sedative effect
so when a patient takes a benzo that is
what it's going to do it's going to calm
them make them
drowsy and you want to educate the
patient whenever they do plan on taking
a benzodiazepine
that they want to avoid any activities
that require
focus or coordination because they could
really injure themselves
or someone around them and the last part
of our pneumonic is o
overdose reversal with flamazanil so
flamazanil
is the antidote for benzos and this drug
should be used with caution whenever
reversing toxicity with benzo
so typically it's used whenever you know
it's going to benefit the patient
a lot more than the risks that are
involved
so as a nurse you want to be familiar
with the signs of toxicity
of a benzo so we know that older adults
who are taking benzos are definitely at
risk for toxicity
and patients who are dependent on the
drug
because abuse may occur so whenever that
happens a patient who does become
dependent on a benzo
in order for them to get the same
effects
those calming tranquil effects from the
drug they have to keep taking
more they have to have higher dosages so
that can
lead to a possible overdose or toxicity
and to help you remember those signs of
toxicity you can remember the word
abused so a stands for altered mental
status so the patient
may appear very drowsy or even in a coma
they can also be agitated or extremely
confused
then b is for bradycardia so slow heart
rate
u is for unable to walk or coordinate
movements
they can have ataxia s is for speech
garbled or slurred it'll be really hard
to understand them when they speak
e is for experienced hallucinations or
memory loss
and then d is for decreased respirations
okay now let's test your knowledge over
the material i just covered by taking
this quiz question
so this question says benzodiazepines
amplify
the effect of what neurotransmitter our
options are
a serotonin b gamma aminoburteric acid
c acetylcholine d
epinephrine and the answer is b because
remember benzodiazepines
amplify that neurotransmitter gaba
because what it's going to do after all
this binding occurs
it's going to hyperpolarize and we're
going to get a decrease
in firing potential which hence is going
to cause
some calming tranquilizing effects to
the patient
so that wraps up this review over
benzodiazepines and if you would like
more free quiz questions or more reviews
over farm you can access the link in the
youtube description
and thank you so much for watching